hello everyone i'm sam copeland i'm a
national master on the content team here
at chess.com
and i'm here today to show you an
incredible game won by leela chessero
against stockfish 8 and the evans
gambit now this game comes from a 200
game simulation match between these two
engines
that is designed to reproduce the famous
2017 match against
alpha zero in this 200 game simulation
leela chesiro won 69
games nice against stockfish eights
five games our estimation then is that
leela chesiro has continued to
push the bounds for chess engines and is
now significantly ahead of where alpha
zero was
in 2017. as said
this game opens with the evans gambit
that's e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop c4 bishop c5
and now the famous pawn to b4 the idea
of the evans gambit is that after bishop
takes b4
c3 bishop a5 and d4 white has built a
very nice pawn center
white has also done this while attacking
this bishop on a5
white also has good development and
access to more open lines
now the defensive task for a human
player as black
has always been very difficult but
modern opening analysis and reviews from
engines like stockfish have really
questioned whether white has
sufficient compensation could white just
end up down a pawn
now in this game we are going to see a
less materialistic engine
leela demonstrate that it is possible to
maintain compensation
throughout the game if you are
sufficiently creative
so in this game we're going to see d6
from black
and now queen b3 and queen d7 for a
human player this looks like a very
suspicious defensive setup
why does the queen want to be on d7 is
it so great here
why is it blocking in the bishop on c8
but actually we've seen this be a very
successful defense one of black's best
for example after pawn takes e5 the best
move here seems to be
bishop b6 fabiano caruana the number two
player in the world
successfully used this to win a
brilliant game against grand master
nisipiano
in a lot of cases black will give back
the pawn but complete development and
have the bishop pair in an advantage
in this game we see something a little
different from leila
we see knight to d2 bishop to b6
pawn takes e5 and after pawn takes e5
leela tries pawn to a4 white includes
ideas of a5 here and also bishop to a3
trying to get the most out of the queen
side structure
now in this position a very natural move
played by stockfish is knight to a5
after queen a2 a big question is can you
should you take the bishop on c4 in this
game and in many games that bishop on c4
is a very important part of white's
counter play
however after knight takes c4 queen
takes e4 white has a number of ideas
they include pawn to a5
knight takes e5 and bishop a3
it's not so easy for black to deal with
all these ideas
so the knight remains on a5 after queen
a2 we see queen to e7
now bishop a3 and the queen slides over
to f6
this bishop looks very very strong but
black's idea is just to play
97 and castle and say i'm really just a
pawn up what are you gonna do
so in this position we see castles we
see 97 black is ready to castle on the
next move
and this is the time to pause your video
and try to play like leela chess zero
how can you maintain your initiative and
keeps black king
keep black's king in the middle of the
board
in this position lila drops a bomb on
stockfish eight
knight takes e5 a brilliant
and daring piece sacrifice after queen
takes e5 we see bishop takes f7 check
and king f8 now the point is not so much
to try to checkmate the exposed king
the king is actually relatively safe
inconveniently placed
but relatively safe the point is much
more subtle and positional
black's pieces are struggling how do you
activate the rook on h8
what about the knight on e7 the knight
on a5 on the rim
what about the other rook in the corner
on a8 now
these are all difficult questions and in
this game
we're going to see stockfish really
struggle to answer these questions
this is a theme you see over and over in
leela's games
its pieces are well placed active
optimized
meanwhile it does a great job
restricting its opponent's pieces
it's also not materialistic about this
it is willing to sacrifice
like in this brilliant game to do this
so here we see bishop d5 and now pawn c6
attacking that bishop
knight f3 attacking the black queen and
after queen f6
this next move is my favorite in this
game
i like knight takes e5 a lot but i love
work a to e1 this move perfectly
combines
tactics and strategy and i just always
love to see the inactive rook on the
a-file developed
so in this position first off you cannot
capture the sacrifice bishop on d5 after
pawn takes d5 we get e takes
there's pressure here on the pin knight
and if you defend then d6
is super strong if the knight moves then
d7
and you have murder on these diagonals
very very beautiful stuff
so after rook a to e1 the question why
have we blocked in this rook on f1
couldn't we have put this rook on the
e-file wouldn't that have been better
wouldn't our pieces have had more scope
in that case well
lila is anticipating with this
mysterious rook move
that over the next few moves lines are
going to open up to advance the f
pawn then you're going to have a strong
f and e pawn supported by a strong
f and e rook the course of the game
shows that this is really the crux
of white's idea so after rook e1 we see
pawn h6 not a very convincing move
and now e5 queen f5 bishop to e4
queen f7 and queen c2 already
right around here i'm suspecting that
the game might be decisive
for leela i just don't see very many
options to contain white's initiative
from here on out
after king g8 bishop takes e7 queen
takes e7 knight d4
the f pawn is getting ready to march up
the board
we see pawn h5 and pawn f4
bishop e6 king h1 and bishop c4
i think this is another instructive
moment we see that leela's not afraid to
trade pieces
as long as progress is being made many
humans would be
reluctant to give up the light squared
bishop that looks to be a very strong
piece
but after the trade here the pawns are
continuing up the board and all of the
white
pieces are really really effective
so we see rook f8 pawn to f5 now we have
an idea of knight e6
so bishop takes d4 and pawn takes d4
the position is simplifying but the
pressure is not reducing
black still has trouble with the knight
on a5 and the rook on h8
meanwhile white's heavy pieces are
amazing as are
these very strong centralized ponds
i'm seeing zeroes from stockfish but
again
i think that this is a decisive
advantage pawn to b6
rookie 3 rook h6 and now pawn to h3
very patient ready to take time to make
left so you're not getting backrank
mated
so you can activate your pieces more
fully
now we see queen d7 rook g3 king h8
rook f to f3 and now queen e8 queen e3
knight c4 hitting the queen and queen f4
with every move the white pieces are
just
encroaching a little bit by a little bit
on the black position
we see rook taft 7 now pawn to f6
you can't take because after the capture
this rook on h6 hangs so that rook falls
back very very sadly
to h7 rook g6 encroaching again
and now pawn takes and e takes f6
more lines are opening up pawn to h4
preventing at least the tripling of the
heavy pieces for white on the g file and
now rook f2
pawn to b5 i think that at this point
we're just saying that stockfish is
struggling for any valid moves and after
pawn takes
we see that stockfish realizes that pawn
takes back allows
rookie two this is a sacrifice but you
can't accept because you get backrank
mated
and after rookie two then if the queen
moves and gives up the e file you have
rookie 6
and then queen e4 and rookie 8 is
decisive
so at this point after the capture on b5
i think that the game is just over we
see queen f8
and just a capture on c6 at this point
white is even
actually even on material and about to
be ahead very very soon
the position is just dominating but in
the computer chess championship
the engines play onto mate in every game
and so we see that here as well
the knight on e3 falls and in a few
moves we're going to see the pawn on
a2 fall as well the maneuvers from leela
to convert this game are a little
interesting as it's willing to give up
pawns to make progress
but ultimately the game is never in
question as it marches its pawns forward
pushing on the c file and also being
willing to
create an initiative against the black
king here's c7
and then after rook takes we see queen
e5 which is really
the finishing move here if you try to
stop the pawns advance with rook f7
then rook e7 is just crushing for
example queen to h5 is going to be mate
it is mate in six at most so after queen
e5 we see desperation from stockfish
spike checks rook check and then work
check again the other rook also gives
itself up
unfortunately the black queen can't give
itself up and after king age seven we
see queen check
and then rook check and mate a
crushing final position i really hope
that you enjoyed this game i certainly
did
and most of all i'm really hoping that
this will inspire you
and maybe some other great players to
try the evans gambit
and be inspired by leela if you want to
check out more games from leila then
click on the playlist that is sitting
right on top of your screen